[Music]
this is what plan a looks like
personal choice personal responsibility
decisions like masks left to the
individual
but with each day and each week this is
playing its part in driving up covered
infections
hospitalizations and ultimately deaths
i'm expecting an incredibly challenging
winter if we don't start taking some
action now professor summers treats the
sickest patients she says now is the
time for the government to make
interventions like mandatory social
distancing i'm an intensive care
specialist i deal with emergencies all
the time that's my job
i'm pretty certain that there is no
emergency for which waiting for it to
get worse before you take any action is
the best way to handle it
cases of covid are up in all but one
region of england and rates are
comparable to march when the country was
in full lockdown despite these warnings
the government says it's not going to
push the button on plan b there will be
no compulsory wearing of face masks or
asking us to work from home in fact
boris johnson says his government
scientists told him this is exactly
where we would be
no handshakes for the prime minister on
this school visit in northern ireland
it's children who are seeing the highest
numbers of cases and that's why there is
a big push to target this age group for
vaccination
we're in a much better
position
going into the autumn the winter now
than we were 12 months ago
incomparably better because of the huge
level of
protection that we got from the vaccines
ninety percent of the adult population
has antibodies right now but we must
fortify ourselves further
so no plan b for the moment instead it's
plan a
but better
vaccinations
and boosters have it done
otherwise you're putting other people in
danger
it's only a little pinprick after all
and it could save your life
the government is confident the nhs will
cope but the health service's own medics
warn it might not but there is agreement
on one thing
the hardest of winters is on its way
harshest joshie sky news